en este distrito de clase trabajadora
ubicado en el oeste de túnez cientos de
jóvenes salieron a las calles una vez
más enojados por la situación económica
del país sus piedras y bombas
artesanales fueron recibidas por gases
lacrimógenos y chorros de agua de la
policía más temprano el presidente del
país
caixa y estuvo de visita en la zona
aunque expresó que toda persona tiene
derecho al trabajo la libertad y la
dignidad también se pronunció contra
aquellos que según él aprovechan para
explotar la miseria de los jóvenes de
túnez nunca han sido ladrones
la gente quiere emplear a los jóvenes a
quienes les gustaría servir no ataquen y
insulten a nadie
tampoco dañen la propiedad privada o las
instituciones estatales el caos llega
después del décimo aniversario de la
revolución de túnez en los últimos diez
años los tunecinos han ganado elecciones
libres y justas pero el desempleo
crónico y servicios públicos deficientes
han dejado a una parte de la población
bajo sensación de olvido
en esa malicia que entiendo porque los
manifestantes están haciendo esto porque
si nuestra situación fuera buena no
seríamos violentos salimos a la calle
ayer porque tenemos hambre los jóvenes
que ves aquí están descuidados y no
tienen comida en casa se van a casa y no
tienen nada para comer
en 2020 el producto interno bruto de la
nación se redujo un 9% además más del 35
por ciento de los jóvenes de 15 a 24
años están desempleados durante la
conmemoración de la caída del presidente
ben alí entró en vigor un cierre de
cuatro días debido a la pandemia de
coronavirus una crisis sanitaria que
paralizó una economía ya frágil